[Musik]
das war ein beispielloser Angriff
deramass der gestern früh startete und
noch immer ist die Lage nicht unter
Kontrolle herzlich willkommen zum ZDF
Spezial wir werden alle Orte an denen
die Hamas organisiert ist und sich
versteckt in trümmerinseln verwandeln so
der israelische Ministerpräsident
Benjamin netanahu inzwischen ist klar
mindestens 700 Menschen wurden in Israel
getötet wohl mehr als 100 wurden in den
Gasastreifen verschleppt über den tag 1
nach den Angriffen die man in Israel nie
vergessen wird Hilke
Petersen Explosionen über Gaza Stadt im
Morgengrauen die israelische Armee
schlägt zurück ein militärvideo soll
Menschen am löchrigen Grenzzaun
zeigen noch immer sind Kämpfer der
Terrororganisation Hamas auf
israelischem Boden unterwegs mehr als
100 Geiseln sollen sie inzwischen
genommen haben so wie die Familie von
Jon seine Frau seine Schwiegermutter und
die beiden Töchter 5 und 2 Jahre alt sie
sollen auch deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft
haben seither warten sein Albtraum zu
sehen auf sozialen
Medien Hamas Terroristen überall um sie
herum das Video auf Social Media zeigt
einindeu meine
Familie en israelische Städte der
Kriegszustand ist ausgerufen
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu entschlossen
Einrichtungen der palästinensergruppe
Hamas zu
zerstören Hamas versteckt sich auch in
mitten von Gaza Zivilisten bei ih zu
Hause in Schulen und Krankenhäusern
Hamas agiert wie die Terroristen vom
islamischen
Staat israelische Reservisten machen
sich auf den Weg Richtung
Süden Streifen jetzt abgeschnitten von
Strom Benzin und Warenverkehr Blockade
durch Israel und massive Zerstörungen
auch an
Wohnhäusern 20.000 brauchen
Notunterkünfte im
Gazastreifen komplette Zerstörung hier
wir waren 150 Leute in diesem Haus viele
aus meiner
Familie auch in den Libanon flogen
israelische Raketen zuvor hatte die
Hisbollah Organisation aus Solidarität
mit Hamas auf israelisch besetztes
Gebiet gefeuert
inzwischen auch solche Bilder von der
israelischen Polizei bei der Befreiung
von
hamasgeiseln an nichts anderes kann
Familienvater Joni Ascher
denken meine Regierung wird meine
Familie retten die israelische Armee
bereitet sich vor auf einen möglichen
Krieg an mehreren Fronten ja und dann
schalten wir nach Israel zu unserem
Korrespondenten Michael beberunge wie
tief sitzt den der Schock über die
Angriffe bei den
Israelis
nach wie vor sehr tief ich hatte heute
Nachmittag die Gelegenheit selbst mich
ins derot umzuschauen die Stadt gleicht
einer Geisterstadt überall noch Spuren
von Feuergefechten Einschusslöchern kaum
Menschen auf der Straße die sind nach
wie vor extrem verängstigt einige haben
uns von den Massakern die gestern
passiert sind berichtte die sie mit
anschauen mussten und sie fürchten dass
noch immer Kämpfer unterwegs sind wir
haben soldatengruppen beobachtet die die
Stadt durchkämmen und wurden selbst
Zeuge bei einem Interview wie wenige
Meter von uns etwa 50 m auf einmal ein
Feuergefecht losbrach also die Gefahr
ist noch lange nicht gebannt und auch
nicht der die Angst der Menschen noch
hat Israel die Kontrolle über die
Gebiete hier rund um den gazerstreifen
nicht zurückgewonnen und was weiß man
denn über die Situation der Geiseln in
Gaza unter ihnen sollen ja auch
Deutscher
sein leider sehr sehr wenig es gibt die
Propaganda wie Videos die die Hamas
veröffentlicht hat die Angehörigen haben
sie darauf teilweise wiedererkannt aber
die Strategie der Hamas ist nachdem sie
erstmal das ganze propagandistisch
ausgeschlachtet haben eine Art
Informationssperre zu verhängen auch um
den informationsort zu verheimlichen und
für die ganzen Angehörigen ist es
natürlich ein wahrer Terror weil sie
überhaupt nichts mehr über den Verbleib
ihre Angehörigen ihrer Liebsten erfahren
und daran wird sich auch so schnell
nichts ändern Israel versucht jetzt auf
Vermittlung über Vermittlung von Ägypten
zumindest Frauen Kinder und ältere
Menschen frei zuubekommen aber dieser
Prozess steht erst ganz am Anfang und
bis es dann möglicherweise zu einer
Lösung kommt wird man fürchte ich nicht
viel mehr über ihr Schicksal erfahren
vielen Dank für die Einschätzung Michael
beberunge ja ermordete und entführte
Israeli wie erleben die Menschen im Land
diese einschneidenden Angriffe Jennifer
Girke hat mit Israelis in Jerusalem
telaviv und an der libanesischen Grenze
gesprochen in der Nacht hatte ich sehr
große Angst letztendlich rief ich eine
Freundin an und fragte ob sie hier
schläft weil mein Mann ja nicht da war
ich kenne Geschichten aus erster Hand
Menschen haben ihre Türen zugehalten die
Hamas hat dagegen geschlagen das Haus in
Brand gesetzt und versucht die Menschen
aus dem Bunker zu
zerren jetzt gerade bin ich im Norden
Israels genau vor dem Libanon und im
Libanon ist die Hisbollah wir wissen
dass wenn die hisbolla mit der Hamas
zusammenarbeitet wird es eine weitere
Kriegsgrund
geben ich weiß nicht mein Ehemann
erzählte mir dass er die nächsten ein
zwei Wochen nicht zurückkommen wird das
macht mich sehr traurig
entschuldigung ich weiß einfach nicht
weiter
mein Bruder mein Neffe der Ehemann
meiner Schwester sie sind alle in die
Armee einberufen worden aber im Moment
sind alle in Israel wie ein felz wir
halten zusammen helfen uns gegenseitig
das ist sehr wichtig in so einer Zeit
ich glaube die Regierung ist sehr
schlecht sie funktioniert nicht die
Hamas ist einfach hier hereinspaziert
wie konnte das passieren und haben
getötet getötet
getötet ich weiß nicht was passieren
wird ich weiß nur dass unsere Armee
stark ist und tun wird was auch immer
notwendig ist um diesen Angriff auf
unschuldige Menschen zu
stoppen wir hoffen dass die Hamas die
israelische Regierung alle
Verantwortlichen verstehen dass wir alle
Menschen sind und wir nicht wollen dass
jemand verletzt wird ich hoffe dass die
Zeiten endlich besser
werden ja und wir schalten jetzt ins
Westjordanland dort leben etwa 3
Millionen Palästinenser und etwa 600.000
israelische Siedler in ramalla ist sten
Höfner Leiter des dortigen Auslandsbüros
der Konrad Adenauer Stiftung guten Abend
wie ist denn die Lage Moment im
Westjordanland der heutige Tag war
relativ ruhig in ramalla und im
Westjordanland es wurde ein
Generalstreik ausgerufen und damit
blieben viele Geschäfte geschlossen die
Menschen blieben zu Hause und verfolgten
vor allem die Ereignisse vor dem
Fernseher aber das ist eine trügerische
Ruhe denn bereits gestern hat die Hamers
aufg ren ihre Anhänger Angriffe
durchzuführen und was wir am späten
Nachmittag und am jetzigen Abend sehen
ist dass es zu Demonstration kommt zu
Zusammenstößen an den Checkpoints das
heißt auch die nächsten Tage im
Westjordanland werden sehr
herausfordernd werden und die
Sicherheitslage ist mittlerweile eng mit
den Zuständen im gaserstreifen verknüpft
obgleich dort die Situation natürlich
noch eine andere Dimension hat wie stark
ist denn die Unterstützung der Hamas in
den palästinensischen
Gebieten die Unterstützung der Hamas war
in den Letten letzten Jahren relativ
stabil und zwar auf einem hohen Niveau
nicht so hoch dass wir in den Umfragen
eine absolute Mehrheit für die Hamas
sehen aber doch eine zumindest
Herausforderung für die im
Westjordanland regierende vertach und
gerade in solchen konfliktzeiten wie wir
sie jetzt sehen mit einer massiven
Eskalation gewinnt die Hamas
traditionell an Sympathien weil sie
einen anderen Politikstil wählt eine
populistische Art des
gewalteinsatzes den viele Palästinenser
in ihrer häufig Perspektivlosigkeit und
Aussichtslosigkeit als vielversprechener
halten als die diplomatischen
Mittel der Vergangenheit und was
erwarten sie jetzt für die nächsten Tage
wie wird's weiter
gehen ich befürchte dass ähm die
nächsten Tage sehr schwierig werden
würden für Israelis und Palästinenser
hier vor Ort die Lage im gaserstreifen
und rund um den gaserstreifen ist
weiterhin nicht vollständig unter
Kontrolle damit befinden wir uns
weiterhin noch in einer chaotischen
Phase dieser
Konflikteskalation die nächsten Tage
werden zeigen in welche Richtung äh die
diese Eskalation sich weiterentwickeln
wird wir befürchten Zusammenstöße im
Westjordanland und die große Frage die
sich viele Stellen inwiefern wird die
hisboller aus dem Südlibanon Südlibanon
noch in diesen Konflikt einsteigen das
wäre noch mal eine ganz andere Dimension
mhm ja in Deutschland wird ja das Ende
der deutschen Hilfen für Palästinenser
gefordert wie ist denn ihre Einschätzung
Vorort glaube was offensichtlich wird
und was nicht nur diese Eskalation zeigt
dass die 30 Jahre des osloystems ähm die
die Zustände im Westjordanland und im
Gasastreifen die dadurch geprägt wurden
nicht mehr nachhaltig sind ähm und das
bedeutet auch dass wir uns in Europa und
in Deutschland Gedanken machen müssen
wie wir mit diesem Konflikt in Zukunft
umgehen wollen und da ist es auch
sicherlich
ratsam kritische Fragen zu stellen ähm
obgleich ich keine Antwort darauf geben
kann wie diese äh Fragen beantwortet
werden sollen aber ich glaube dass wir
uns noch mal stärker mit dem Konflikt
auseinandersetzen müssen weil wie wir
sehen ist er mit nichten gelöst und die
Eskalationsstufen werden immer größer
und damit ist auch die Befürchtung eben
da dass wir noch sehr viel mehr Leid
sehen werden ja mit nichten gelöst ja
vielen Dank Steven Höfner in
ramalla wie konnte es soweit kommen wie
konnte die Hamas einen solchen Schlag
gegen Israel ausführen unbemerkt von den
israelischen Sicherheitskräften und so
hoch gerüstet unterstützt wird die Amas
von der libanesischen Hisbollah und dem
Iran frühere Unterstützer haben sich von
der abgewendet auch saudi-Arabien hatte
sich Israel angenähert
über die Player im Pulverfass nost Elm
Tison als Joe Biden und Anthony blinken
am Samstag vor die Kameras traten war
ihre Hoffnung auf eine diplomatische
Meisterleistung die Aussöhnung zwischen
Saudi-Arabien und Israel dahin für den
möglichen Deal hatte beiden gar heftige
Anfeindungen in Kauf genommen weil er
das Gespräch suchte mit dem saudischen
Kronprinzen bin Salman im
Verantwortlichen für den Mord an einem
amerikanischen Journalisten und weil er
auf Benjamin Netanyahu zuging der aus
Sicht vieler Israels Demokratie aushölt
aber jede Aussicht auf die historische
Aussöhnung hat der Krieg nun
zerstört das wird einen dramatischen
Einfluss haben auf jede Hoffnung für
eine Normalisierung der
saudisch-israelischen Beziehungen jeder
Hebel den die US-Regierung zu haben
glaubte um Netanyahu zu Zugeständnissen
an die Palästinenser zu drängen ist
zusammengeschrumpft auf
Null der menschenverachtende Terror der
Hamas könnte eine Gewaltspirale auslösen
die gesamte Region in einen Krieg
stürzen Israels Antwort einen Teil der
arabischen Welt in Aufruhr versetzen
genau das wäre in seinem Sinne am
Dienstag hatte Irans geistlicher Führer
Chamenei behauptet die Palästinenser und
andere Kräfte würden Zitat das
Krebsgeschwür Israel bald schon
auslöschen w er vielleicht von dem Plan
der
Hamas was wenn nun auch die iranisch
gesteuerte hisbolla im Libanon eine
zweite Front eröffnet dass die
hamasangriffe am Samstag eine
saudisch-israelische aussönung zuichte
machen sollten hält die US-Regierung für
möglich ob Iran dahinter steckt werde
geprüft in diesem Moment haben wir
nichts was eine direkte Beteiligung des
Irans an der Planung und Ausführung
dieser Attacke belegt aber das schauen
wir uns ganz genau an und sehen wohin
die Fakten uns
führen die CIA wertet nun alle
gesammelten Daten der letzten Tage neu
aus auf der Suche nach Belegen für einen
größeren Plan ja und über die
Sicherheitslage möchte ich jetzt mit dem
terrorismusexperten peter Neumann reden
guten
Abend guten Abend Frau pieer ja viele
sprechen ja von einem neinel Moment für
Israel wie einschneitend werden die
Angriffe den Nahen Osten verändern
also ich glaube sehr einschneidend man
muss sich mal vor Augen halten da sind
jetzt 600 Todesopfer in Israel zu
beklagen wenn man das auf die
Bevölkerung in Deutschland umrechnet
wärend das über 6000 also eine riesige
Zahl ich glaube für Israel geht es jetzt
erstmal darum die eigene Sicherheit zu
sichern das bedeutet inkursionen aus dem
Gazastreifen zu verhindern die Grenze
mit dem Südlibanon da kommt ja die
hesbolla möglicherweise her die Grenze
zu schließen eine zweite Front zu
verhindern natürlich auch die Geiseln
zurückzubekommen und dann Gaza sozusagen
ja dort Hamas sprichwörtlich das Genick
zu brechen so hat das ja netanahu auch
angekündigt und das wird bestimmt dauern
ja das gelikckbrechen was glauben Sie
denn war das strategische Ziel der Hamas
sagen es ja der Gegenschlag Israels wird
ja heftig
ausfallen ja richtig also ich glaube es
ganz wichtig zu verstehen was da den let
Letten Monaten und Jahren passiert ist
nämlich ein Aussöhnungsprozess ein
Normalisierungsprozess zwischen den
arabischen Staaten und Israel und wir
waren kurz davor dass sogar
Saudi-Arabien die wichtigste
Regionalmacht einen Friedensabkommen mit
Israel unterzeichnet hätte das ist jetzt
durch diese Offensive kaputt gemacht
worden und da ist es auch wichtig zu
verstehen dass Hamas nicht nur autonom
handelt sondern dass Hamas einen
Hauptsponsor hat und das ist der Iran
also das ist wichtig dass man da auch
das das das regionale Bild im Blick
behält ja die Hamas hat ja auch viele
Geiseln genommen was ist denn das Ziel
dahinter also ich glaube das sind zwei
Motivationen erstens ist es natürlich
eine riesendemütigung für Israel 100
Israelis auch Ausländer sind jetzt in
der Gefangenschaft der Hamas im
gazaastreifen die Hamas kann mit denen
machen was sie will zum zweiten glaube
ich ist es auch so eine Art und das
klingt jetzt mal aber es ist so eine Art
Köder um die Israelis in den Gaza
Streifen reinzulocken dort
möglicherweise in Häuserkämpfe zu
verwickeln und dort in Israelis alle
möglichen Probleme zu bereiten mit dem
Ergebnis dass möglicherweise die
Israelis hässliche Dinge dort tun und
dann Hamas eine Art täteropferumkehr
betreiben kann also nicht mehr Hamas als
Täter sondern Israel und was glauben Sie
was heißen die Ereignisse in Israel für
die Sicherheitslage
weltweit
also ich glaube jetzt erstmal ist es
ganz wichtig und das ist auch ein Appell
an die Sicherheitsbehörden in
Deutschland wirklich jüdische
Einrichtungen in Deutschland ganz Europa
zu schützen die werden jetzt nicht nur
in den nächsten Tagen sondern
wahrscheinlich über Wochen und Monate
gefährdet sein und das das muss
unbedingt passieren vielen Dank peter
Neumann ja das war unser ZF Spezial zur
Eskalation in nost ein Tag nach dem
Überraschungsangriff der Hamas mehr
Informationen dann später im
heutejournal oder jederzeit auf ZDF
heute hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
Terra x von uns auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen